-Our first guest tonight
is a "New York Times"
best-selling author
and host of the wildly popular
"The Wendy Williams Show,"
now in its 12th season.
Please welcome back to the show,
here in studio,
to tell us how she's doing
our very good friend,
Wendy Williams.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
-[ Laughs ]
How you doing?
-How you doing?
-Hi, Seth.
-Hi, everybody!
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
Wendy, what a delight!
-Thank you for the invitation.
-You know, I was lucky enoug
to see you -- have you
on the show during the pandemic,
but it wasn't the full Wendy
Like, getting the full Wendy
head to toe,
is very important to me.
-Right.
-So thank you for being here
-Thank you, Seth.
-And how are you?
You are back in your studio.
-Mm-hmm.
-You have limited audience back.
What are you at?
-We are like 75%.
-75%.
-By next week,
we're gonna be like 85%.
And by the week after that
we might be 100%.
-That's very exciting.
-Yeah.
I talked to you about this
before on the show.
Your audience
is a full party atmosphere
-Yeah.
-I can imagine it's only more so
now because people are so happ
to be out and with each other.
-And people have saved
their best, craziest outfits
you know,
the glitter and the sparkle.
-Sure.
-You know how my crowd does.
-Yeah.
-I love it.
-And they've had no way
to show that off.
-Correct. Correct.
-Good.
-And they show it off.
[ Laughter ]
The girls need prayer cloths
The guys are looking like
Tom Jones, you know?
-Oh, really?
-Mm-hmm.
-You're seeing
a lot of chest right now?
Do you think chests are gonn
be back as a -- for men?
Are we gonna see more
man chests this summer?
-Well, I don't know.
-Okay.
-Probably.
-I hope so.
You got an honor.
You got one of
the highest honors that can be
given to a celebrity.
You got your own
Madame Tussauds wax figure
-Right?
-Are you happy with it?
-Yes!
-Were you worried
before you saw it?
-No.
-Because some of them
turn out bad.
You weren't worried?
-Well, apparently,
what they've done is they've -
they've --
Technology has made it where
they can do it even better
-I see.
-So they all flew from London,
and we spent hours --
Excuse me.
I'm sorry.,
My mouth is watering.
Thank you for the popcorn
and goodies in your green room
-Oh, did you eat salty food an
now your mouth is drying out
-No, no, watering.
-Do you need water?
-No, no, I don't want water.
-Okay, got you.
-Look, but they came,
and they were in the --
on my studio set with the chai
and everything, measuring.
They measure.
They measure the width
of your eye balls, like,
from one to the other.
-Now with what?
Are they measuring it
with, like, lasers?
-Yes! Yes, yes, yes.
-Really?
-Yes.
-You weren't worried about
getting measured with lasers
-Yes.
-Okay.
Well guess what -- it paid off
-Yeah, it was worth
the sacrifice.
-Because look at that.
I mean, come on.
-Yeah.
I love it.
-I mean, I would be over
the moon if I were you.
Yeah.
I am.
-I'd be very worried
if I got it.
I don't think I'd measure well
-Why?
-I just think
I have weird angles.
-Just -- [ Chuckles ]
Don't we all?
-You have
a perfectly symmetrical face
Don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, Seth.
-That's a beautiful ring.
-Thank you.
It's a --
-Do you get all the channels
with that?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, a flower ring
is my good-luck ring.
It's been that way since
even before the talk show.
-Really?
-I've had this for ages.
But I got a new one done,
and this is the new one.
-It's beautiful.
-And because I'm not married
anymore, you know,
and I just wanted something.
Because it's a lonely finger
-Mm-hmm.
-You know,
but not a lonely woman.
-Right.
-Do you know what I mean?
-How is it --
Now, is that going well, post --
-Wait.
I just want to tell you.
-Oh, please.
-So, I asked the jeweler,
I said,
"Look, make it to cover."
Like, make it a big --
So nothing's lonely anymore.
-Oh, that's great, yeah.
It's full coverage.
-Right.
-It's really great.
-Thank you.
-And how is -- are you dating?
Now that we're post-lockdown
-Very much so.
-Good.
And is it going well?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
Are you maintaining
a 6-foot distance?
-Mnh-mnh.
-Okay.
Thank you for your honesty
[ Laughter ]
-Just saying.
-Do you make sure
everyone's vaxxed?
Is that, like -- Do you want
to see the little card?
-Everyone's got to be clean.
-Okay, good.
-And everyone's got to pay
-Pay for what?
Oh, for dinner and stuff?
-Well, I'm just a girl.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Snorts ]
[ Both laugh ]
-What was that noise?
-'Cause I was thinking,
"How much is a Gray Papaya?"
-Gray's Papaya?
-I'm simple.
-You would be happy
if a man took you on a dat
to Gray's Papaya?
-Well, not the first date.
-Oh, I see.
So you need --
So you need something fancie
early on,
but then you get simple
as it goes on?
-Like this, fancy, you know.
-I see.
You're like -- you're like -
It doesn't --
Every night
doesn't have to be five-star
You can, you know --
Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
Se--
-No, look,
you're being coy about it.
I get it.
You don't just want to lay out
a blueprint for any single men
who are watching.
-Correct. Correct.
-They got to work
to find these answers.
-Right.
-I can't just give, you know
the steps
that a man needs to take.
-You seem to know a lot, though.
-Look, I want to get
to the bottom of it.
You were on --
-"The Masked Singer."
-You were on
"The Masked Singer."
Did you -- How much did you have
to say about your outfit?
-I love it. There were thousands
of Swarovski crystals.
And I was lips,
and it was so heavy.
And they wanted me to stan
and walk with it.
Finally, it was my choice.
I said, "Look, give me a couch
Can you guys just push me out?
And I sang Odyssey's song
"Native New Yorker,"
and I was guessed right away
-Really?
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, right away.
-Do you think --
What do you think --
I mean, here you are, post -
Do you think it was your voice
or do you think
it was the clues?
What do you think gave it away
-Because I was laughing
in between.
-Yeah.
-And, you know --
♪♪ You should know
the score by now ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-A lot of secrecy
in "The Masked Singer," right?
-Yeah.
-Did you enjoy
the whole process?
-I did.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
That's a really good operation
-They run a good --
They run a tight ship?
-Mm-hmm.
-How long did you have to be -
Like, I've heard they, like,
just, they throw, like,
a burlap sack over you to ge
you in and out of the studio
-From the time you land
in the plane --
They send a plane for you,
first of all.
-They send a plane?
-Right.
-Oh, wow.
-From the time you land,
they throw a burlap sack
over you
and shuttle you off
to the hotel.
And you cannot be seen.
You can't shop.
You can't go out with friends.
You can't do anything
in between doing it.
And all can you do
is sit in your hotel room.
Like, literally, they won't even
let you order room service
because the room-service perso
might recognize you
as being who you are.
-So how many days is it?
How long are you cut off
from society?
-Well, I was there for a week.
-Wow!
-And it seemed like a month.
-I would guess so.
-Yeah.
-So what happens for food?
-Well, you know,
I had people with me.
-Okay.
Oh, so they can order food
-They would go get
the Roscoe's, you know.
-Okay, got you.
Right.
-You know.
-What was the face --
You said Roscoe's,
which is famously chicken,
and then you made a fish face.
All right.
-Doesn't your mouth water when
you like food that you like?
-Oh, I see.
When you water --
when your mouth --
when you go like this...?
-Mm-hmm.
-I mean, I love, like --
I don't think I do that.
-You just did.
-Yeah, I was --
[ Laughter ]
I didn't do it --
You know what?
We'll talk about this
during the commercial.
We'll be right back with mor
from Wendy Williams.